also here tonight is republican senator
of missouri
josh josh uh senator thank you so much
for joining me today
uh a passionate conversation about what
the democrats are doing
but what the republican response need
needs to take place
so your rising star you are considered
one of the leaders in the new gop
what do you propose well how about
bringing jobs back to our urban core
from overseas why don't we start there
why don't we start with the disastrous
trade policies and economic policies
that the liberals in step with the big
corporations have pursued for 30 40
years and who's been hurt most working
folks african-american working folks
latino working folks
white working folks asian working folks
you name it they're the ones whose
communities have suffered
as these jobs have been shipped off to
china as these jobs have been shipped
overseas to the lowest bidder to the
lowest wages the democrats have made
american workers compete with slave
labor
and they've done it in order to get rich
so the big corporations could get rich
it's time to bring those jobs back and
create opportunities in our urban core
in our rural areas everywhere for
american workers that's where i'd start
well it starts their senator
but respectfully this audience they
already know about that
right they watch fox we we we we discuss
this
every day how do you get new people in
because
i got to tell you you guys just lost
georgia and part of it was because
you guys did not attract new voters so
how do you take that message
and tell it to the people that you're
not reaching i think what we have to do
is we've got to be the party
of the working people in this nation and
you look at how donald trump grew this
party in 2016 and in 2020
and made it the most racially diverse
background the most racially diverse
number of votes that a president
republican president has gotten since
1960
that was donald trump's record since
1960 how did he do it
he focused on concerns of working people
working african-americans working latino
voters working whites everybody working
folks
we've got to be the party of working
people that means we've got to be the
party of getting jobs back into this
country we've got to be the party of
higher wages for working people
we've got to be the party of new
opportunities for workers to get job
training to get skills training without
having to go pay an expensive four-year
education that they don't want
if we're not the party of working people
then we're not going to have a future as
a party i think that's what
donald trump has showed us and that's
the path forward well i got to ask you
senator what's your future you running
for president
i'm not i am not but i tell you what my
job is to serve the people of missouri
and we are a state a diverse state with
working folks of all racial backgrounds
all across our state my state and we
need policies that will bring
jobs back to this country you know
immigration is another one we've got to
quit prioritizing illegal immigrants
over
american workers we need a pro-jobs
pro-worker policy in this country
i got to tell you senator it sounds good
we will be watching you this audience
will be watching you and we hope to have
you back soon thank you so much thank
you